next question is from Martin this
technology actually make life easier or
does it just make life more hectic I
think that there's a macro answer to
this and a micro answer to this at the
macro level technology makes life easier
or at least removes friction from so
many aspects of life everything from
business inventory management to
financial transactions hotel and airline
reservations I mean so many of these
issues which in the past required
sometimes the writing of letters through
snail mail or other mechanisms way way
easier at the individual level
particularly depending on on how one
chooses to interact with technology and
particularly if you're suffering from a
sort of smartphone addiction type of
thing yeah technology can make life more
hectic in some ways but I don't think
there's any doubt at the macro level Pat
that technology is making so many of the
things that we do in modern life much
easier it's also important to point out
that technology makes us so much smarter
because we're able to look up
information and at the push of a button
be able to find out what the answer is
all right smart I think we are smarter
because you know we can find out that
information so much easier and we can
work more on applying it yeah I guess I
don't disagree with that it's more of a
question of is that actually making a
smarter or is it allowing us more time
to focus on other aspects with our
brains and just remembering fact I don't
know I think it's just easier you can
look up the atomic mass of carbon or
something in a split second you don't
have to go digging through your books to
find it out right and that's time that
you could be used to apply the knowledge
yeah and we don't have any more of those
you know in the past when you were out
with friends and people said you know I
think that in 1973 there was a
particular plant you know airline
accident and someone else's really was
they I don't remember that it basically
stopped there and until you could you
know maybe get to a library or before
smart phones get home to your internet
connection
you genuinely didn't know and you
couldn't continue the conversation now
you can just look it up and then the
conversation continues that seems like a
good thing yeah I think a lot of people
long for those times but as I said I
think we're becoming a much more
intelligent society because of the
technology that we
have and I think that will allow us to
progress a much faster rate than we were
before
are you worried though about technology
addiction I see so many people who
cannot go more than a few minutes
without looking at their phones and
there's this sort of self-fulfilling
vicious cycle where if anytime your mind
is unoccupied you pull out your phone
and you sort of fill the void by
scrolling your Facebook feed you're
perpetuating the training of your mind
to expect something like that every time
your mind is at rest for a second and I
don't think it's good at all I think we
have to remember what spider-man's uncle
said in this scenario which is that with
great power comes great responsibility
yeah so yet do it do the right thing
don't use your phone too much but if
you're using it to learn I think it's a
good thing was that spider-man uncle who
had that with great power comes great
responsibility is from spider-man yeah
okay I wish we want to look it up I wish
we had some way to figure out what is
true but are you being serious about
that I thought that that's a quote that
went back a very long time well I'll
have to look it up yeah maybe you can
look it up on your phone I I'm only
seeing uncle Ben from spider-man okay
well I don't know much about it but I
thought that that went back anyway okay
well this is an instance where I guess
the smartphone's are useful